hey how's it goin my name its Bearpaw
we're playing a lake view cabin this
game is based on a real story I was that
summer I remember it like yesterday
Tina Turner here how's it going everyone
okay my [ __ ] god what they actual
[ __ ] that is one ugly [ __ ] and she are
my leg my [ __ ] leg what the [ __ ] is
fish leg you're coming with me leg mine
god that's disgusting
we need to find a key it's you and me
from now on leg if we can't make it out
of here in lab then no one will ever
live a blanket oh yeah you can choose
characters the Cuttino Turner is a big
big trouble
but uh Sally's salamander is still good
to go I'm Sally I have a bottom what
happened here
hey checking all great Tina [ __ ] died
I don't even know how fabulous well
we're just gonna have to play with
Sandra Bullock Sandra Bullock Sandra
laughs ice cream I love ice cream all
hand me ice cream ah monkey fun I love
monkeys
I agree chickens my kids should be
killed
now that looks safe let's go in right
this looks completely 100% safe my ice
cream yeah I'm so upset now oh [ __ ]
that's scratched off my [ __ ] ah
they're [ __ ] me and [ __ ] the [ __ ] man
ah ah ah
don't go in there guys that's awful so
if you don't know this game is all about
kind of trial and error
ah I have him again now I bet the
problem here was that the hell happens
is change
ah
at Brad
what's up [ __ ] yo what's up [ __ ]
where's everyone going oh god my leg
it's okay
it needs a leg anyway oh god what was
that Sam I'm sure it's no big deal
let's go this Oh God it's a rat pink can
ate me are you kidding me
ah I love this game so [ __ ] awesome
Oh God not this [ __ ] [ __ ] up all right
everyone in the car Center in the cart
Sandra okay well we're a little bit
shocked but we will live up all right
well let's ask our neighbors for more
for more ice creams brats
hello their neighbors happen I love
burns bottom a sad I must be in the
wrong room okay ah funny hip shop you
guys did it [ __ ] Heisenberg killed me
this is [ __ ] up I can't [ __ ] say
anything right great great quick hey I
killed one I killed one I have your
friend
you're coming with the ha [ __ ] the rat
[ __ ] well that didn't really turn out
that well did it well okay let's turn
off the alarm okay that's fine it's fine
Oh feel good no no no no no no no here
we are all right no happy yeah
I have a present my Telemann okay Nana
[ __ ] stop hitting me oh that really
really [ __ ] hurts don't you know that
what a fun a great is dark now the [ __ ]
did this happen everyone just left me I
thought we were friends
now I swear I've seen a shotgun here
somewhere so I should be able to shoot
this at least once let's do it
do it
hey [ __ ] suck on those tits
whoa
you know what let's take a seat take a
seat right there man I love this cartoon
it's my favorite okay well ow I'm not a
sucker till I need it
stop hitting me super annoying that
[ __ ] hurt a lot
I can't feel my face all right taste ah
no no the rat the rat King ah ah [ __ ]
didn't do that much progress but life is
not all about progress it's about having
fun and did we have fun today I think
probably maybe thank you boys for liking
this video and all my god the pictures
coming
I can't this game